[Música]
estelas de humo en los cielos de kiev
evidencia en una nueva oleada de ataques
aéreos rusos sobre la capital ucraniana
el enemigo lanzó un ataque masivo en el
territorio ucraniano en el que se
lanzaron misiles de cruceros desde el
aire y el mar así como misiles de avión
s-300 y s-400 dirigidos a objetivos
críticos y de infraestructura energética
en regiones del este centro oeste y sur
de nuestro país
el enemigo utilizó más de 69 misiles la
defensa aérea de nuestro país destruyó
54 misiles
los residentes de kiev se refugiaron de
nuevo en las estaciones subterráneas del
metro muchos de ellos no tienen
calefacción y suministro de energía en
sus casas debido a que los constantes
ataques han afectado la red eléctrica
del país
tras los ataques de este jueves un 40%
de la urbe quedó sin servicio eléctrico
harkyff la segunda ciudad del país
también fue blanco de los cohetes rusos
y al sureste en saporilla algunos
residentes resultaron damnificados
me desperté con todo temblando
desmoronándose
estos ataques masivos tienen lugar un
día después de que Rusia rechazara la
propuesta de paz de 10 puntos del
presidente bolodimircelenski el kremlin
insiste en que cualquier intento de paz
debe reconocer la soberanía rusa de
crimea gersón saporilla Daniel
ucranianos anexados ilegalmente por
Rusia el Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores de Rusia se pronunció al
respecto
consideramos esto como una idea tan
delirante y otro truco publicitario de
Washington que ha estado tratando
recientemente de presentar al régimen de
kiev como un pacificador
al igual que esta propuesta de paz
rechazada otros intentos de menguar la
guerra tampoco han tenido éxito como la
creación de una zona desmilitarizada en
la central nuclear de saporilla la más
grande de Europa para evitar una
eventual catástrofe radioactiva debido a
los bombardeos de ambos bandos